it's great to welcome to the program
today hunt Alcott who is a principal
researcher at Microsoft Research also
associate professor of economics at New
York University and he worked on a very
interesting study which I've looked at
in some detail hunt but the reason
you're here is you know much more about
the detail than I do about what happens
when people who are sort of normal users
of Facebook stop using it for a month
and what I found interesting about your
study and I'm curious why you did this
is that you excluded people who were
already light users of Facebook but you
also excluded people who were extremely
heavy Facebook users what were you
trying to target with your study sure
the the hope with our study was to
recruit a sample of people who were
fairly representative of the Facebook
user population but would also have
we're quitting Facebook would have
enough effect on their lives that it
would be statistically detectable and
also people who were giving us serious
answers to survey questions and those
two additional requirements were why we
limited people who said they used
Facebook more than 10 hours a day which
sounds a little much
and also people who said they use
Facebook 15 minutes or less per day
we're quitting Facebook probably
wouldn't have a big impact on their
lives
okay so we've we've started to have a
lot of scholarship and serious studies
of social medias impact on people at the
societal level
Jonathan Hite has a very interesting
presentation he's been doing related to
the impact of early social media use on
suicidality particularly in young girls
but also young boys and there's the
general idea that I think a lot of us
have that social media use particularly
heavy social media use isn't good for us
but we don't often define exactly what
that means or sort of think about how we
might be able to measure it so as
someone who is looking to study this in
a quantitative and measurable way how do
you believe we should be evaluating the
impact that social media use
on us I think there are several ways the
there are outcomes like subjective
well-being and subsets of specific
objects within subjective well-being
that I think matter a lot
they were happiness scale satisfaction
with life scales depression scales
things like that and so I think these
are valuable measures to understanding
the impact that social media and other
aspects might have on our lives however
you might also worry that that's
insufficient because something could
make us happier as measured on a
subjective well-being scale but also
have a number of other impacts on our
lives that aren't captured in happiness
and so that's why I think measures of
revealed preference and a post
experiment usage of Facebook are really
important so after we encourage you to
detox or take a break from Facebook for
a while do you come right back to the
platform immediately and use it as you
did before
or do you re optimize your and rethink
your use and use it less than you have
in the past and that to me we do find
more of the latter that people who we
paid to deactivate use Facebook less
after we stopped paying them and that to
me is perhaps the most important measure
that we find in our study that people
are rethinking how they use Facebook so
we'll get to the sort of after the detox
period is over phase but to sort of kind
of top-line the results for our audience
what results did you see for the people
that stopped the using Facebook relative
to the control group during the detox
period we found outcomes we found the
following things so the activating
Facebook increased subjective well-being
it also decreased news knowledge
and decreased political polarization so
flipping that around from deactivating
to what Facebook might be doing to us
these results suggest that Facebook
reduces subjective well-being increases
news knowledge and increases political
polarization the news knowledge one is
interesting because identifying whether
someone knows more or less about sort of
generally speaking what's going on in
the news is a separate question from
whether we are I don't know better
participants in the political system
that we have there kind of two separate
questions and it's not totally clear and
I'm curious what what your thought is
about it either from the researcher
personally just because we may be less
aware of the day to day news that's
going on on the basis of a Facebook
algorithm feeding us articles it thinks
we might be interested in does it follow
that we are also inferior participants
in our political system or does that not
necessarily bear out I think that's a
great question I think part of it bears
on what are the news knowledge questions
that that we asked you know you can
imagine people are extremely
knowledgeable about what happened
yesterday on the front page of the paper
but that doesn't translate into a deep
understanding of the complexities of
public policy debates so I think that's
one issue certainly a second issue is
that as you say news knowledge or even
deep understanding of public policy
debates is not the only thing you want
people to vote you want people to share
their knowledge with other people so we
have you know partial and incomplete
measures of those things so now let's
get to the after the study portion you
said that as a sort of general finding
you did see that people who detox went
back to less Facebook usage than they
had before the detox period started are
there any numbers we can attach to that
yes so we measured how quickly people
reactivate
their Facebook accounts so during our
experiment of course we had paid people
to deactivate which basically means
you're staying on Facebook entirely the
treatment group even after about two
months you know about two months after
our experiment is over five percent of
the treatment group that we had paid to
deactivate is still deactivated so
that's not very many people it's one in
twenty but this is an extreme case of
people who have said I'm not coming back
at all that was against only 2% of the
of the control group that had not
reactivated so I think that's one
important statistic another one is of
course for the other 19 and 20 people
who have come back to Facebook how much
are they actually using it how many
minutes per day
we have self-reported measures of that
and people say that they are using
Facebook I think it's on the order of 20
percent less in the group that we had
paid to deactivate compared to the group
that we hadn't paid to deactivate and
that's about four weeks after this study
was over so what we don't know is what's
happening now were were four months
after the study and did five months
almost it's possible that the treatment
group has at this point had their usage
returned much closer to what it was
before I'm curious what you think are
the sort of pernicious elements of
significant Facebook use I mean there's
a lot of different theorizing and
hypothesizing there's the idea of this
kind of variable reward system like a
slot machine where you pull the lever
you scroll the feed you might get
something interesting you might not and
that encourages people to just kind of
indefinitely continue scrolling there's
the idea that you are comparing your
life in total with just the best things
that people you are connected to our
choosing to post and that this creates a
sort of unrealistic comparison or
expectation about maybe what what your
life should be like I mean we get you
don't give me a sense of in doing this
research what you think are the
concerning aspect
so in our paper certainly we have we
avoid the word pernicious we're trying
to you know report we're trying to
report the the data that came out of the
experiment we also have a series of
qualitative interviews that we partnered
with some qualitative researchers to do
interviews and those helped to flesh out
these sorts of issues so what we can say
is that after deactivating many people
expressed sentiments like I felt less
stressed about what my friends were
doing online I realized that didn't
matter as much a second thing people
felt less stressed about was political
issues because you know people tend to
get sort of high political news with
heightened tensions either the comment
boxes and things like that so I think
those are the sorts of things that came
out in the qualitative interviews that
were done and come out and then text
responses I can say for myself
personally what what were the things
that mattered for me I have not used
Facebook much at all and I would say the
last three four or five years and the
way that I had been using Facebook was
that I would be sitting at work I was an
assistant professor needed to get tenure
write computer code write papers etc and
you know you get tired in front of your
computer and you take a break and the
way that I was taking a break was to
keep sitting at my computer and just
open up Facebook for a while at some
point I realized I personally felt like
I was better served by getting up and
walking around the block or something
like that as my breaks
is there any picture rising that you can
point to that gives us a sense of what
is a sort of healthy amount of Facebook
use or social media use we have the sort
of trend towards less is better there's
probably some amount that that may not
be acutely negative with some
significant diminishing marginal returns
that exist beyond a certain
what's your sense of what a healthy
social media diet might look like it's a
good question and I share your intuition
that you know at least for me personally
if I were using Facebook 6 hours a day
that would be too much um and I think
you know we have a concern whenever any
one of us is spending too much of our
time doing any one thing within the
confines of our studies data it was
interesting that we didn't see a lot of
heterogeneity in terms of the impacts of
Facebook or impacts of deactivating
Facebook on the outcomes that we
measured so we saw no statistically
detectable difference in the subjective
well-being effect for example for people
who have been used in facebook a lot
compared to people who have been using
Facebook loss and that to me is an
interesting fact it could be just that
our sample size is not large enough to
detect these things but it suggests that
you even people who are using Facebook a
bit less also benefit from deactivating
as measured by subjective well-being
that so let me see if I understand that
it's it sounds like what what you're
saying is that if you have some people
who were using at 6 hours and go down to
for some people who were using at 6
hours and might go down of course after
the detox period to something like one
hour that different people benefit in
two different degrees there's no sort of
consistent reduction in the percentage
of use or raw time that correlates with
a particular benefit it sort of seems to
be different for different people that's
exactly right so for example I'm looking
at our appendix figure a 12 from our
paper and that's a figure that looks at
the impact of subjective well-being for
separately for light users and heavy
users and the estimates of the effects
on subjective well-being for those two
groups are are almost exactly the same
so if you're a light user deactivating
is good for you if you're a heavy user
deactivating is good for you on average
that's what we find and then to your
point about there being lots of
heterogeneity certainly there are some
people you know within those light and
heavy sub groups where the activating
was probably great for them and other
people for him deactivating was bad for
them what were the most common
activities people were doing instead
during the deactivation period right and
this is a this is a critical question
Remy the control group during the
deactivation period so while the
treatment group was deactivating the
control group continued using Facebook
about as normal they said they were
using Facebook about 60 minutes per day
so quitting Facebook is both about using
Facebook laughs but also about what
you're doing with that extra time and so
here's what we saw we saw people spend
they people told us that when they
deactivated Facebook they spent more
time watching TV by themselves they
spent more time by themselves without
screens so this would be things like
exercise or cooking without a screen in
front of you and then people also tell
us they're spending more time with their
friends and family and they say that
when we asked about specific activities
they said yeah I went out to dinner more
more last week I went to the mall more
last week those sorts of those sorts of
activities that's fascinating because I
think most people I'm guessing now I
think most people if asked wouldn't
imagine that simply by scrolling
Facebook less or not at all they would
actually have more dinner plans right
like it seems like such a different sort
of vertical but you actually did find
that in the study consistently that's
that's right so we have a list of about
10 offline activities that we asked
people about so specifically did you do
this thing in the last week going out
for dinner was one of the things that
increased among the group that we had
paid the deactivate along with getting
together with friends and spending time
with your parents
those were the three specific individual
activities individual offline activities
that people told us they were doing more
of and and it's interesting right
because another model of Facebook use is
I'm mostly doing it when I'm on the
subway or you know taxi or otherwise
wasting time and so if you take away my
social media use I'm just gonna stare
out the window and think more which
might be good or bad for various reasons
but our data suggests that at least
people tell us that when they deactivate
they're actually doing more things in
person with other people absolutely
fascinating and we're going to be
linking to the study we've been speaking
with Hunt Alcott who is principal
researcher at Microsoft
research also an associate professor of
economics at New York University hunt
really a pleasure speaking with you
today thanks very much for having me